- [Tutor] In chemistry,
it's important to distinguish
between thermodynamics and kinetics.
For example,
if we think about the conversion of carbon
as a solid in the diamond form
to carbon as a solid in the graphite form,
thermodynamics tells us what will happen.
Will this conversion happen
at a specific temperature?
Whereas kinetics tells us when
the conversion could happen.
Let's start with thermodynamics.
We can calculate if this
conversion will happen
at room temperature of 25 degrees Celsius
by calculating the standard
change in free energy
for this reaction at that temperature.
To calculate the standard change
in free energy for this reaction
we need to know the standard change
in free energy of
formation of the products.
And from that we subtract
the standard change
in free energy of
formation of the reactants.
For this conversion
our product is carbon
in the graphite form.
And because carbon in the graphite form
is the most stable
elemental form of carbon
at a pressure of one atmosphere,
the standard change in
free energy of formation
of carbon in the graphite
form is equal to zero.
Next, we think about our reactant,
which is carbon in the form of diamond.
The standard change in free
energy of formation of carbon
in the diamond form is
2.84 kilojoules per mole.
Looking at our balanced
equation for this conversion,
we're converting one mole of diamond
into one mole of graphite.
Since there's a one as a
coefficient in front of diamond,
we multiply the standard
change in free energy
of formation of diamond
by one mole of diamond.
Moles cancel, and we get
negative 2.84 kilojoules
as the standard change in
free energy for this reaction.
Instead of kilojoules,
the units could've been written
as kilojoules per mole of reaction.
Because there's one mole of
carbon in the diamond form
for how the balanced equation is written,
we could write a conversion
factor of one mole
of carbon in the diamond
form per mole of reaction.
And because the standard
change in free energy
of formation of diamond
is equal to 2.84 kilojoules
per mole of diamond,
moles of diamond would cancel out
and give kilojoules per mole
of reaction as the units.
Because the standard change
in free energy for this
reaction is negative.
We know that the conversion
of diamond into graphite
at 25 degrees Celsius is
thermodynamically favorable.
Next, let's think about the
kinetics of this reaction.
If we look at the structure of diamond,
each carbon atom is covalently
bonded to four other carbons.
For example,
this carbon right here is bonded
to four other carbon atoms
and the tetrahedral geometry
around the central carbon atom.
Graphite has a very different structure.
In graphite,
carbon atoms form covalently
bonded layers or sheets.
And these layers or sheets
are held together by
London dispersion forces.
So in order to convert
diamond into graphite
we would have to break a
lot of carbon-carbon bonds.
And that would take a lot of energy.
Since it takes a lot of energy
to break the carbon-carbon
bonds in diamond,
if we look at the energy
profile for this reaction,
this reaction would have a
very high activation energy,
symbolized by EA.
And the higher the activation
energy for the reaction
the slower the rate of the reaction.
At room temperature,
it's estimated this reaction
could take billions of years.
Therefore we would say this reaction
is kinetically unfavorable.
Finally, let's summarize
what we've learned
about the conversion of
diamond into graphite.
Thermodynamics answers the
question, will the reaction go?
And the answer to that question is yes.
At room temperature,
diamond will convert into graphite
because delta G naught for
the reaction was negative.
Kinetics answers the question,
how long will it take?
And the answer to that question
is it would take billions
of years for diamond
to turn into graphite at room temperature.
The reason why the reaction is so slow
is because of the extremely
high activation energy.
So even though the reaction
is thermodynamically favorable
at room temperature, because
the reaction is so slow,
the reaction is kinetically unfavored.
And for all practical purposes,
the reaction doesn't happen.